[Musik]
im saarländischen homburg baut die stadt
diese neue straße ins gewerbegebiet an
der remise doch für gießen unter 30
meter langen abschnitt einschließlich
wendehammer gibt es keinen bebauungsplan
mit anderen worten die stadt hat hier
für 500.000 euro komplett rechtswidrig
ein schwarzbau errichtet grundsätzlich
sind ja gesetze da dass man sich daran
hält dann sollte sich auch die stadt
homburg daran halten
ja ich hab's von kabul ich finde das
echt unverschämt so was überhaupt so
leute überhaupt so was wir machen ohne
genehmigung aber nur als bürger den kopf
schütteln ist im jahr 2017 plant die
stadt homburg eine erweiterung des
gewerbegebiets um betriebe anzusiedeln
eigentlich soll die neue
erschließungsstraße nur bis hier gebaut
werden
tatsächlich will sie um mehr als 100
meter verlängert inklusive
straßenlaternen kanalisation und einem
breiten gehweg alles illegal denn
offiziell dafür gar nicht gebaut werden
es gibt für diesen grund und boden
keinen bebauungsplan
obendrein wurde dieser bauabschnitt wie
gesetzlich zwingend vorgeschrieben die
europaweit ausgeschrieben die stadt
hamburg hat hiergegen ein ganzes bündel
gesetze verstoßen
jeder normalsterbliche der ohne
baugenehmigung irgendetwas errichtet hat
mit irgendwelchen rechtlichen
konsequenzen zu rechnen
notfalls mit abriss und der staat setzt
sich dann offensichtlich mal wieder ganz
deutlich über das hinweg wie das geht
kann ich mir vorstelle ich kann
nachvollziehen das einfach so machen
kann
im hamburger rathaus macht man das gar
nicht den versuch das bau und
planungsrecht kleinzureden schriftlich
heißt es man habe ihm der zuständigen
verwaltung bereits konsequenzen gezogen
um ähnliche vorgänge in zukunft wirksam
verhindern zu können wurde das bauamt
bereits im sommer 2020 umstrukturiert
und eine prozesssteuerung bau
controlling eingeführt
diese einsicht kommt für viele hamburger
ein bisschen spät
eigentlich darf so etwas nicht passieren
dafür sind ja die leute da dafür gibt
was er sich welche gremien und was weiß
ich alles gesagt überhaupt nicht das
geht nicht bei einem privatmann und erst
recht nicht bei einer stadtverwaltung
mittlerweile kümmert sich die
staatsanwaltschaft saarbrücken um den
fall
sie soll ermitteln wer für den teuren
schwarzbau verantwortlich ist